[Applause]
Ryann app is one of the most innovative
companies on the planet and yet it also
manages to be one of the most hated yeah
yeah we've all heard of companies like
Tesla or hyper Li but but let's be
honest it's going to be years before
those companies actually change lives as
if they ever do Ryanair they have
created a revolution already and I'm not
just worried about European
Ryanair's sway can be felt worldwide but
on the other side of things it's hard to
find someone who doesn't hate this
airline this is partly due to the
efforts of its CEO Michael O'Leary he
seems to have worked really hard to
become the man you love to hate with
quotes like this one but we need fewer
people queuing to go to the toilet how
do you get fewer people queuing to go to
the toilet charge them for us or how
about this one wants to sit beside a
really fat ass on board we have been
frankly astonished at the number of
customers who don't only want to tax fat
people but torture them well there's
actually another reason people hate Ryan
Aaron if you've been following this
channel all my others you might already
know that I live in Prague in the Czech
Republic
now I parners on this channel they live
over in Madrid in Spain and until this
very month the cost of a flight to go
from here in Prague to Madrid cost about
250 American dollars but this year well
run air came down and they managed off
of Prague to Madrid roots for about 90
dollars and what did the other airline's
do in response to this well they were
also forced to lower their prices and
this didn't just happen between Prague
and Madrid this happened all across
Europe anywhere Ryanair operates the
rest of its competitors hats put down
their prices in order to remain
competitive this meant lower profits or
even potential bankruptcy
[Music]
just have a look British Airways in the
year 2000 they carried over 46 million
passengers but just eight years later
they didn't even carry 33 million and of
course those big airlines like British
Airways or Lufthansa or Iberia they
spent a fortune buying ads in the media
and well because it will this ad buy
they won the love of journalists sands
well you know who didn't have much love
for journalists well that would be
Ryanair because they never really bought
any ads well despite this bad reputation
there are only a few companies that can
claim to have changed an entire industry
the way that Brian Eyre did and as I
said before this is not only a European
thing the Ryanair effect can be felt
around the world except perhaps in Latin
America so the first question we have to
ask here is how did Ryanair change the
world
wider regions like Latin America need a
company like this and most important of
all how does Ryanair manage to offer
these ludicrously low prices well today
we are going to answer all those
questions but first let's take a look
back at the history
why is Ryanair so cheap back in the
1980s a Madrid to London flight cost the
equivalent of 700 dollars back then in
Spain this was the average monthly wage
everyone understood that flying well it
was a luxury
[Music]
I mean at the end of the day planes
they're really expensive and there
wasn't really anything anyone could do
nevertheless the reason why it flights
for that expensive actually had little
to do with the technology and it had
much more to do with politics yes this
really is true because back then air
routes they were based on agreements
between governments for instance the
French government and the American one
they had a deal
so only French and American Airlines
could fly between Paris and New York
City the same happens with the rest of
the European countries Airlines they had
essentially a monopoly over the routes
that they operated
so there really was no incentive for
them to lower fares because they could
simply make a fortune selling $700
tickets back then it was really only
British and Irish people who could enjoy
Ryanair's lower fares but then in April
of 1997 things they changed forever this
month any technically qualified airline
in the European Union plus Norway and
Iceland will be able to run services
inside any other country all of a sudden
all these European carriers they could
compete against each other but they
didn't really know how this is why they
heavily invested in advertising and more
luxuries they make that our food more
comfortable seats and even gave
corporate gifts to passengers Ronna
instead they bet on a totally different
strategy
[Music]
[Applause]
the other airlines are asking how they
can put up fares we are asking how we
could get rid of them saying this in
1997 it was totally crazy of course
there were already over budget airlines
like the American Airlines Southwest but
rather they wanted to go even further
this is why they found new ways to
reduce the cost to an absolute minimum
for example the landing cost depended
partly on the fares with our lines paid
to the airport's landing at Brussels
central airports is costly but 60
kilometers south there is Shana Roy
Airport which offers way lower landing
fees simply by choosing to flight to
that Airport
Ryanair they saved a fortune
another cost-saving policy was utilizing
the same airplane model for all of the
routes and this airplane
it was the Boeing 737 other companies
like Lufthansa they worked with over 14
different types of airplanes
this means they needed 14 maintenance
technicians each of them specialized on
a different model of aircraft rather
instead they could do the same with just
a few experts this means that while
Lufthansa needed hours between flights
to do maintenance checks
Ryanair needed half that time and of
course add to this the rest of the extra
costs that they save during the flights
do you want to eat on the airplane well
that's extra do you want to carry on
more baggage yeah that's extra to want
to choose your seats every year Ryanair
finds new ways to reduce costs for
instance a few years ago on the backs of
their seats they started posting adverts
but the real turning points in this
company came in the year 2000 this was
the time when Michael O'Leary made a
decision that changed the entire
industry forever the travel agents take
the [ __ ] out and shoot him what have
they done for passengers over the last
years in the year 2000 Ryanair was the
first company to create a website where
you could book tickets online prior to
that it was impossible to buy your own
plane ticket unless you lived close to
the airport so travel agents they were a
pretty essential middleman and of course
these travel agents they charged
commissions and these commissions went
up to 30%
now instead passengers could just go to
the website find the cheapest flight and
then buy us today this is completely
normal but back then it was a revolution
and he put lots of travel agents out of
business with all of this by the year
2010 Ryanair could offer tickets for an
average price of 40 US dollars I mean
that's cheap but it's pretty ridiculous
when you consider the $700 ticket that
we were talking about before
[Music]
alright alright so now you might be
wondering why are we saying cheap
flights such a revolution that think
about it since Ryanair expanded its
business in Europe the amount of
passengers has tripled pay attention to
the chart here because we're talking
about much more than tourism here thanks
to cheap flights students exchange
programs have multiplied by five since
2007 in fact if you are watching this
video from anywhere in Europe you might
have studied abroad with an Erasmus
program or have a friend who did and the
same goes for labour mobility which is
tripled in a decade it would be hard to
measure all the small businesses that
have been born thanks to cheap flights
they can even allow the most modest
freelancer to find clients in another
country
but hold on for just a minute because
there's another detail that we must keep
in mind here if you look carefully you
will see that while flying has increased
in Europe Latin America seems to be
immune to those changes and didn't I
just say that the Ryanair effects it was
worldwide
I mean well what happens in Latin
America the Ryanair effect I know you're
thinking Ryanair just operates in Europe
I mean how could they have such a big
influence on the rest of the world well
I'll let you draw your own conclusions
take AirAsia they were an airline owned
by the Malaysian government at the
beginning of the 2000s they were on the
verge of bankruptcy then in 2001 the
Malaysian businessman Tony Fernandes
bought it and followed the Ryanair model
that had started to work in Europe
AirAsia they adopted the slogan now
everyone can fly and they offered to the
first low-cost flights on the continents
suddenly Kuala Lumpur to Macau could be
done for less than $90 as happened in
Europe Asia then saw the birth of many
other low-cost airlines from Lyon air of
Indonesia to Cebu Pacific in the
Philippines even a country as poor and
as big as India has seen at the amount
of passengers tripled in just 10 years
but hold on again for just a minute
because there's still that part of the
planet which seems immune to the Ryanair
effects and this area as we mentioned
well it's Latin America for example a
cheap flight between Bogota in Colombia
and Mexico City costs four hundred and
sixty dollars just compare that with the
86 dollars that you could pay going from
Kuala Lumpur to Taipei and in case you
want to check the distance both are more
or less the same
and the saying goes if you want to go
from Lima in Peru to La Paz in Bolivia
this is a three hour flight and it costs
$600 and yes this is more than the
average monthly wage in most Latin
American countries so now you might be
wondering why is it so damn expensive to
fly in Latin America why don't they have
some Ryanair like company the answer
lies again in politics in other words
legislation in the region has made it
impossible for a Ryan airline company to
appear if an airline wants to work in
Brazil they need to have at least 20% of
their capital owned by Brazilians and
two years ago this percentage it was
even higher this is why when Avianca or
a Colombian carrier wanted to open two
markets in the country the government
forced them to start a brand new company
with their headquarters in Brazil thus
of a young current Avianca Brasil are
two entirely different companies despite
the fact that they do belong to the same
group but Brazil they're not the only
country that protects their own Airlines
[Music]
[Applause]
until the year 2016 Argentinians who
wanted to fly could only choose between
two companies Argentina latam a private
carrier and are really nice Argentina's
a state-owned airline for decades the
Cristina Fernandez the Kirsten
administration made sure no other
airline could compete with these
airlines and the same goes for the
airports another one they said that
Ryanair could cut costs thanks to taking
off at landing of cheap airports well
this is possible in Europe but because
of one out of every four airports are
managed by a marriage between the
government and private companies
[Music]
thanks to this airports must compete
with each other by offering better
services and lower fares it's not by
chance that half of European air traffic
comes from private airports Latin
America though it's a different story
most of their airports are managed
solely by the government's if there is
no competition they simply have no
interest in reducing fares in other
words Ryan errors failed to have an
effect on this region because of
politics and well what are the
consequences of this well despite the
fact that there's many Latin American
countries have grown economically in the
past few years flying is still a
privilege for the rich this is my vision
I've been to the mountaintop I've seen
the light so now the question becomes do
you think Latin America should
liberalize its airspace do you think
that everyone could benefit from a
company like Ryanair operating in his or
her country well please do leave your
answers in the comment section below
because we'd love to hear from you
meanwhile if you want to know how
Ireland stepped out of poverty and
became the powerhouse that it is today
well do click on this video also do
visit reconsider Mediacom the podcast
that provided the vocals in this video
that are not mine and as always I'll see
you in the next video and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear more
of my lovely voice don't forget to check
out the reconsider podcast at reconsider
media.com and we consider as a podcast
that challenges you to reconsider your
views by providing context but we don't
do that thinking organ
[Music]